aujourd'hui je ne fais rien parfois on
dit coincer la bulle ou tout simplement
buller mais d'où sort cet étrange
expression quel lien entre l'oise yves t
et la bulle on cherche évidemment un
rapport avec un prêt est couvert de
petites fleurs la réponse se trouve bien
dans un champ mais sur un champ de
bataille au milieu du 20ème siècle la
précision d'un tir d'artillerie
nécessitait que la plateforme de l'engin
soit parfaitement à l'horizontale à
l'époque pas de gps ni de lasers les
militaires utilisent est au niveau
il ajustait jusqu'à ce que la bulle soit
coincé entre les deux petits traits une
fois l'opération réussie
ils attendaient les ordres pendant ce
temps plus long qu'une capsule de les
confiner il ne faisait rien si ce n'est
jeté un oeil de temps en temps sur la
bulle pour vérifier qu'elle était bien
coincé pas bougé
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus vous pouvez
également voir ou revoir celle des jours
précédents en cliquant sur le côté
gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour et
pour être sûr de ne rater aucune et bien
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche
aller à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes toujours confiné et en restant
lien